faites l'amour pas des murs proclame la
banderole les effigies de michail
gorbatchev souris c'est le 25e
anniversaire du mur de berlin
côté ouest fanfare zerbe le mur de la
honte est aussi un monument aux morts
13 août 1961 dès le petit matin les
maçons comment se faisait sous la
protection de l'armée est allemand
nikita khrouchtchev le numéro un
soviétique réclamer le départ de toutes
les forces d'occupation des familles
sont coupés en deux les allemands de
l'est comme pu se réfugier rallier tous
les moyens sont bons pour s'enfuit du
tunnel à la montgolfière depuis 27 ans
77 personnes y ont perdu la vie en 1963
devant une table antilles est le
président kennedy lança phrase célèbre
je suis un berlinois aujourd'hui version
ouest le mur devient un exutoire coloré
côté est les 55 km qui coupent berlin en
2 ont été modernisées quatre fois la
surveillance électronique remplace les
champs de mines et les engins à tir
automatique sans vie kilomètres de murs
bordeaux si la route qui relie
berlin-ouest à l'allemagne fédérale 27
ans après des points de passage ont été
aménagés entre l'est et l'ouest
les relations commerciales entre les
deux pays s'améliorent quelque porte
donc existe mais comme l'expriment les
graffitis du mur le plus dur est d'en
trouver la clé